an investigation is underway after a
police officer shot and killed a deaf
man in Oklahoma City 35 year old mag
deal Sanchez was shot Tuesday night in
front of his home neighbors say that
Sanchez could not understand officers
commands police say that Sanchez
approached them with a metal pipe in his
hand and they were at his home
investigating a hit and run crash
involving his father Omar Villafranca is
outside the Oklahoma City Police
Department
Omar good morning good morning the
Oklahoma City police chief says this is
a criminal investigation which is
standard in police involved shootings a
neighbor tells us that he was yelling at
officers outside before the shooting
telling them that Sanchez was deaf
surveillance video from a nearby
business shows the moment a truck driven
by mag deal Sanchez's father crossed an
intersection and is hit by another car
the truck rolls over then drives away
police tracked the truck to Sanchez's
home the first officer to arrive at the
house lieutenant Matthew Lindsey says
Sanchez approached him holding a metal
pipe a second officer sergeant
Christopher Barnes arrived a short time
later
lieutenant Lindsey drew his taser
sergeant Barnes pulled his handgun
they both discharged their weapons after
Sanchez didn't respond to verbal
commands Oklahoma City Police Chief
William city in our training if we have
an officer that has the Taser
who's going to deploy the Taser we have
another officer with cover fire Julio
Rios says he and other neighbors were
frantically shouting at the officers
telling them Sanchez is deaf and could
not understand them I believe they did
hear me because 101 turned around and
looked at me he also claims Sanchez used
what he called a stick as a means of
communication not as a weapon the guy
does movements he don't speak he don't
hear so mainly it's hand movements that
he does using a sign language
interpreter Jr Wren injure a
representative with the Oklahoma
Association of the Deaf says he's
concerned with the police department's
ability to deal with the death why
didn't they use another option rather
than just going to deadly force chief
city says his officers are taught how to
deal with these kinds of situations
we've
they had training with persons who are
deaf we had some training in 2013 and
we're always open to new ways of dealing
with the public with disabilities the
Sanchez family did not want to comment
neighbors are also telling us that the
shooting was caught on a home security
camera but that that video is now in the
possession of police now the officer who
fired those fatal shots is on paid
administrative leave viana an
unfortunate story Omar thank you